welcome to the NewsHour we begin in West
Jerusalem where tens of thousands of
Israeli protesters are demonstrating
outside Parliament they're angry about a
number of judicial changes being
proposed by the far-right government it
includes measures that many say will
lessen the Court's Powers the knesset is
debating one item in the proposed
changes on Sunday and is expected to
vote on it by Monday if approved the
Supreme Court will no longer be able to
reject political decisions made by the
government the plans to change Israel's
legal system have angered many and led
to Nationwide protests for many months
critics say the bill is a threat to
democracy and a rival rally in support
of the government is taking place in Tel
Aviv thousands have turned out there to
encourage the government's plans many
our supporters of the right-wing
Coalition
is live from West Jerusalem on Laura two
different pictures of what's been going
on there talk us through what's been
happening in West Jerusalem
two very
ditches in indeed now I'm currently
standing outside the knesset I just want
to show you the blue building behind me
that's where the debate has been going
on around this reasonable standless
reasonableness standard bill now just
behind me you can see there's a security
forces of tightened security around the
knesset and about 200 meters behind this
kind of sterile Zone you have thousands
tens of thousands of protesters I was
wading through them earlier you see a
sea of blue and white flags people
raising the Israeli flags and shouting
out for democracy but also calling this
far-right government criminals for
introducing this bill I've been speaking
to people earlier they are incredibly
angry on this side however just a few
hours ago at just at the Western Wall
inside the old city of Oxford East
Jerusalem you saw people from both sides
praying together and then debating at
the bill and we've also seen thousands
of people at a protest in Tel Aviv in
support of the bill so it just goes to
show how polarized it is but we're
certainly seeing more people coming out
in their tens of thousands vehemently
opposed to a bill that they say would
take away their democracy
and Laura Addington mix as well Elite
forces former security Chiefs and
Military reservists all piling on the
pressure on Benjamin Netanyahu would
Reserve this saying that they will opt
out of service in protest against this
bill what more do we know about that
oh I mean I'm trying to count the number
of reservists who are now saying that
they will not turn up for military
service on Monday if this bill passes
now the bill is being debated in
Parliament at the moment that continues
through to tomorrow and then around 2PM
local time they will have a vote and the
reservists that started around 10 000
reserves in the last couple of days
these people are from all different
units from intelligence to Air Force
pilots across the board saying they
won't turn up there was a parallel
letter written from the intelligence
from Mossad and shinbad saying they will
support them in the last hour another
thousand members from the Israeli
intelligence service said they will also
not turn up to work if this bill has
passed so certainly
um a lot are standing against this Bill
Benjamin Netanyahu did hit back and say
you you know this is going to cause a
big problem for Israel's security at
what we don't know at the moment Israel
Security will not tell us this is a red
line for them to tell us whether this
will affect the security of the country
or not
Laura many thanks for that Laura Khan
there in West Jerusalem
now let's take a look at some of the
reasons why so many protesters are angry
the full package proposed by Israel's
government will reduce the Court's
Powers it proposes giving the Israeli
Parliament the ability to override
Supreme Court decisions with a simple
majority of 61 votes
it would allow politicians to choose
which judges to appoint at the moment
judges are selected by an independent
panel the changes would also remove the
Supreme Court's ability to review the
legality of what's known as Israel's
basic laws which function as its
Constitution president Isaac Herzog has
vocally opposed the proposal saying it's
pushing Israel to the verge of legal and
social collapse
senior political analyst he joins us
from Paris with more in this and Marwan
your recent uh piece on aljazeera.com
describes what's happening in Israel as
a struggle between two forms of Zionism
within one leading Coalition a struggle
bordering on what you describe as civil
war that's quite an assessment can you
explain what you mean by that
actually the term Civil War has been
used by countless Israelis and some of
their own supporters in the United
States I only posted as a question
because I think there is a civil Strife
a civil conflict going on in Israel and
I also believe like a good number of
Israeli commentators and intellectuals
that even if tonight or tomorrow by
noontime the Israeli government and the
Israeli opposition reach some sort of a
compromise that will not be the end of
the Schism in Israel it will not be the
end of the division and it will not be
the end of this ongoing crisis that is
far deeper than a governmental crisis
what's going on in Israel is a really
deep secular religious divide uh divide
between Zionism of pre-1967 or more
Ashkenazi more liberal more secular type
of Zionism
against a post-1967 more Messianic more
apocalyptical more fanatic
and certainly a more militant type of
Zionism that
insists on taking control of all of
historic Palestine or what they call the
land of Israel and this Chisholm is
really now taking place within Israel
itself where the militants and the
Fanatics want to change the laws in
Israel wants to overcome and marginalize
the Supreme Court and when they want to
impose their own autocracy religious
autocracy in Israel
and Moen where does this leave Benjamin
Netanyahu himself I mean in the past
he's shown himself to be a pragmatic
leader prepared to Cozy up with any
political party that's going to make
sure that he remains in power but he now
appears torn between battling the
country and facing off against members
of his own coalition
it is true it is also true that this
entire crisis on the governmental level
is of his own making
Yahoo
just to remind our viewers around the
world has been indicted on three various
corruption charges he's really basically
considered widely in Israel and Beyond
as a liar as a deceiver as corrupt and
in so many ways he continues to win
elections as a head of a tribe of sort
because of his populism because of his
lies and deception that it's almost
known to everyone there's a certain
comparison to be made with the United
States and former president Trump but
that's not the time for it now anyway
all to say that this is part of his own
making and the reason why there are so
many opposition parties that will not
sit in government with him the reason he
finds himself cornered by five other
religious Ultra Orthodox Ultra Zionist
religious parties is because none of the
others who served with him in government
before trust him no more because he lied
to all of them again to remind our
viewers the head of some of these
parties have served with Netanyahu
either as heads of his bureaus or as
part of as a government but none of them
trust him anymore not only because he's
been indicted on corruption but because
none of them trust serving with him
because he continuously lied to them
anyway all to say this is netanyahu's
power grab he is trying to marginalize
the Supreme Court he's trying to
marginalize the Judiciary so that he
could rule without any limits on his
terms without any limits on the fact
that he could be indicted and judged and
yet continue to serve just like his
minister
to be Minister Mr ariadere the head of
another Tribe Called Chas the sporadic
religious Jewish party who's been
indicted and judged and imprisoned on
charges of tax evasion but wants to
become Minister of Finance under
Netanyahu imagine the Paradox these are
the sorts of things that are happening
so it is not just fanaticism it's also
corruption that is going on and
Netanyahu insists on this sort of a
corruption slash fanaticism to continue
unabated in Israel and lastly and
briefly I mean given the amount of uh
pressure on Netanyahu at the moment
hundreds of thousands of people on the
streets of Tel Aviv and West Jerusalem
members of the military saying that they
won't uh turn up for service is it
possible that this law could be watered
down not necessarily it's nearly
u-turned but watered down at least
yes and I'll tell you why briefly
because there are two objectives of this
new laws that they want to pass one is
to make sure that they continue to serve
in government and that the Supreme Court
and no other Judiciary and no other
official in in government or outside
that will be able to stop them from
serving as elected members regardless of
their record the other pillar has to do
with how they want to transform Israel
from some sort of an illiberal democracy
to a total autocracy of sort that's a
more long-term project they could wait
for that but for the time being as long
as they can get the compromise where
they can continue to serve without the
Supreme Court stepping on on their
rights to serve refuel as elected
officials then I think they could reach
a compromise but that compromise will
not be the end of the story
by the way many thanks to that Mom and
Bashar Al Jazeera senior political
analyst